oh playing a strong player okay this
will be
perhaps a more serious game
um and we'll have a pierce
or maybe a modern when are we getting
all
geostream
um someday
you just have to keep reminding me it's
easy to forget
i already said that i might stream
scrabble later
oh let's transpose to aponziani ponziani
uh it's like a d6 panziani actually
i usually like to play h3 here which
kind of loses a pawn
but that's okay
black's not taking it though which is
kind of sad
so the idea if black were to take it in
this position
or in this position there's d5 and queen
a4
and that would win a knight it's a nice
uh
nice ponziani tactic
that's why when you're black you
sometimes have to be careful of this
potential queen check
do i like listening to music while i'm
training
training
[Music]
i'm trying to think what it means to
train these days
because i honestly don't actively
i guess i don't have a normal like
training regimen for chess
a lot of the chess i play and sometimes
study
is on stream um
i'll listen to music when i take walks
like music or podcasts
but i guess if i'm studying chess i just
it's it's better if i don't have any
distractions
i'll probably be studying more over the
coming weeks for this
um because i am not a gm
i'm trying to do some some daily tactics
some opening prep might look into like a
few books
too
might order like some of the the agar
books
okay so this is a pleasant position
uh it's my center black's a bit low on
space
i think i'll play a4 it's not clear what
black is
doing here and just preventing b5
entirely
and sometimes these positions require a
more slow play where you just
you sit you slowly improve the opponent
has less space
i'm still trying to figure out my my
optimal
piece placement
okay i think this is okay like before i
have bishop b1
and this is one way to play
i kind of regret playing a4 because now
i can never play a3
but the bishop stays alive
yeah normally i'd like to go for this
maneuver but then
then i lose a pawn
question is how to
[Music]
how to proceed because the bishop stuck
which means the rook is stuck
i do have e5 e5 takes takes
knight moves
rook a3 first just idea rook c3
looks reasonable actually
not too concerned about d5 does not have
e5
thank you elijah tachenko elijah
tachenko
solving for five months in advance
yeah i'll definitely be streaming five
months from now
unless i retire but that's unlikely
i really appreciate that five months
from now will be
will be june i learned my lesson from a
few days ago
i would have said may but yeah june is
five nine five months from now
okay so black wants to play this move
um i think i'll start with rook c3
there's also bishop f4 just defending
the pawn
i think bishop f4 is a bit more flexible
because i might want to play rook e3
also drama with three dollars
oh your blitz is rated 1250 or 1700 in
puzzles
uh that's pretty normal yeah it's very
normal for your puzzle rating to be
higher than your
whatever your online implicit rapid
ratings are
and i think most people can relate
hi krishan welcome back happy new year
thanks for the new year bits hello eric
have you tried peppermint tea oh
um not recently but
at some point in life i'm a little bit
indecisive here i think i'll play this
move
or i'm just trying to figure out what my
like long-term plan is
the benefit with rookie 3 is i over
defend the pawn
and then i can mobilize my knight but
then my bishop kind of gets stuck
yeah i think i'll play this
target the c file
thank you j3 bnt
solving for three months so i did have
unexpected peppermint recently
i told this story i think the my last
stream
a few days ago when was it
it was a morning of new year's eve so
it was like 6 a.m december 31st
i decided to get starbucks
and i ordered
wait i have to focus here i'll tell the
story after i make a
move queen b3
slowly but surely
i ordered a london fog
and the barista
the barista went rogue and rather than
making traditional london fog
the russo made a peppermint london fog
that was really really good
london fog is usually earl grey tea with
steamed milk
it was like a tea latte but then there
was some like peppermint goodness added
to it it was really good
so that's my peppermint story
okay what to do
maybe this knight can maneuver and then
i can play f3
it's a bit strange but i have time
my position is still young
oh that's a good move
wow i was kind of blind to that threat
thank you zippy zippy gifting subs
okay i have this move
but then knight h5
how to do this
queen
i'm kind of just losing a pawn
i could go completely insane
some knight g4 idea
much love eric and chat hope your day
has been good
oh thanks for the much love i think i'm
gonna go insane
but willingly
involves stacking an exchange
i'll try and explain my reasoning so i'm
threatening this
i mean the big problem with this move is
knight h5 but my point is to play knight
g4
ah my bishop
also my rook is hanging too
the hope is to get like some counter
play against h6 i mean mainly against
the king as well
yeah this is taking a turn for i mean
sharp chaotic territory
thanks for yeah thanks people for
cheering and
subbing and i'll thank more people
probably after this game i gotta stay
focused
opponents higher either than me
okay so clearly like if knight takes
bishops i fork
pretty sure my opponent sees that so i
think the critical line is knight takes
g3 queen takes g3
i'm still threatening a fork but also
threatening to win the pawn
and then there's some idea to take on h6
with the bishop
after i move like king here or here um
because knight f6 would be then possible
so i didn't really calculate so much
beyond this
i'm just hoping that there's
compensation
next time you get e4 e5 and f3 as black
could you play an elephant d5
x5 e4 instead of stafford i don't know
about that
that's like
yeah that's like uh i'm cheating on a
lover
i i'm kind of loyal to the stafford but
maybe
um i guess it depends on the situation
i haven't played an elephant in a while
actually
i also haven't looked into the elephant
so closely so i'll have to
probably need to look into it first to
get inspiration
wait what i'm threatening the queen the
rook and
[Music]
okay so i'm winning the queen
material too that worked out really
nicely
the question is how to
how to progress probably e5
e5 is nice because it opens a bishop but
also closes down black's bishop
really my main plan is to get the queen
probably to e4 only square
that's not uh covered by black
and then threaten mate
so now i can play queen g4
um
queen f3 yeah queen f3 looks nicer
because i hit the pawn and threaten
this or this
looks really nice i'm gonna have to
analyze this game afterwards
because i i really thought i was in
trouble but maybe
maybe the idea just worked out
okay so now
if i take the pawn
[Music]
i mean queen f5
my choices choices
and also take this way
i mean there's a line where i force the
king to f8
and then lift the rook
i think i'll start with this move and
then decide between this or this
but probably just taking
yeah now there's there's looming ideas
of queen h7
also pawn e6 also knight coming in
you'll always play f4 for good measure
[Music]
also lifting the rook
so many ideas here
hey it's emo only mode
nice together break from from the words
get some some dose of symbols
okay the f4 looks nice
really just solidifying the pawn
[Music]
and this doesn't really get in the way
of anything so i still have the rook
left idea
and there's really no reason to play
this move just because the king
moves over and the king might be
more attackable on g8
especially when the rook comes in
oh vips don't yeah i don't need to
comply with emote only mode i forgot
about that
oh okay opponent's going for counter
play
oh what to do
rook g3 i win the bishop
yeah this is good enough
so the calculation is rook takes d2
queen h7 king f8 then i take with the
rook
uh threatening mate in two if king e7 i
still take
i guess there's king d8 never mind
okay so here i can take and knight's
still hanging so
important to check here
and now
[Music]
taking threatening meat
if i play queen f5
i guess i'll go for uh and bring in the
knight the
knight to e4 really gotta watch my time
so one one concern
a bishop g could be cool
now let's go for ah let's go for this
threatening the rook
i'm just trying to calculate like an
easy win i am a bishop
fear me oh i don't fear you i don't
think
you should fear me
yeah these pieces make all the bishops
afraid
how am i not meeting oh i'm winning in
the night
the rook has to move to defend and then
i take the night
ooh tricky
okay plenty of time
okay let's go
oh i'm sorry chat that maybe you had to
had to wait so long in emote only mode
i got the job done that was an
interesting game
um that was nice i didn't uh
didn't flag at the end thanks togi the
win bits
yeah i'm not sure what to make of this
game actually because it felt like
i just lost control like it was a nice
opening
maybe a4 a4 was maybe a small
positional mistake just because yeah
like b5 isn't
really the move black wants to play
because then i play a4
and it's probably nice for me
[Music]
i'm just curious what the engine will
come up with and there's a lot of moves
that
uh are playable
the engine plays very slowly like queen
b3 a3
like rook c1 okay
so things got messy
i guess when black played queen e7 yeah
i just wasn't aware of the
the fact that my apon is a target
i was just doing my own thing
and then i realized i'm losing a pawn
and came up with this idea
and i'll admit when i played knight h i
didn't even like see i was preparing
this
i was just trying to like dance around
and play f3
but then this move put me into some kind
of panic mode
and knight h5 yeah knight g4 was uh it
was a nice counter attack
to threaten the pawn of course if here
it's triple
triple pork this is a pin yeah pin plus
fork
so black took here i took here i think
this was a critical moment
that oh stockfish just says i'm
winning
oh wow
yeah i thought somehow back should be
better
but maybe this is all good for me
it's weird because i'm just threatening
these two things and even after
there's no pin i can still get away with
taking
because of the the fork in the end
um
maybe okay f5 engine move and things
get crazy that was a fun game though
hope people enjoyed it
i was really not expecting to get a
ponziani
after d4 like playing d4 d6
i guess we just transposed though
which tea on my store is my favorite
uh this one
i'm drinking it right now egyptian
licorice
oh it's my move uh let's play
i'll play london i'll stick with my main
repertoire
yeah it's warming warming and naturally
spicy sweet
opponent's here and wants to play chess
that's nice
um i'll play yeah we'll transpose now
into a pierce
oh it's um it's a feldor
it's an interesting line like white
could take
but black is usually happy to get like a
queenless middle game
i could transpose to a ponziani i think
i did this last time actually
encountered this variation
[Music]
wait did i play this opponent the other
day
i did we played the same line
i knew this opening looked familiar i
had a cool game the other day against
this opponent
which i actually i checked with
stockfish
i played h3
oh maybe yeah we played a really cool
game
where i kind of messed up in the middle
game but then
i made it work because the blunder
turned into a sacrifice which turned
into a mating attack
um and this is what he played yeah
so now
i'm going to do the same thing i did
last time there's a trap here if knight
takes pawn
i play d5 knight moves and then queen
queen a4 uh would win the knight
it's a nice kind of ponzi any tactic
but black's not falling for it
so i remember last game
[Music]
uh yeah we played exactly the same thing
and at some point black played a6 and i
played a4
which turned out to be a little bit of a
inaccuracy
because after a6 a4 black was able to
take
and put the nylon b4 and play a5
so i'm going to try and do something a
bit different here
if a6 i'll probably play like a3
black's just going for b6 whoa it's
tally tally thanks tally tally
and there's been a lot of reads so far
maurice ashley
tally tally oh there's someone else
earlier too shout out to talitali
if you're just joining i'm playing
[Music]
i'm playing chess opponents playing a
little bit passively
but also i logically
the rook usually wants to be here i mean
black wants to target the
the pawn i just want to hold my ground
thank you tamarax solving with prime
yeah so i'm going to play a3
very simply uh preventing knight b4
and the line takes takes because knight
b4 would attack the bishop and the pawn
i just don't want to want to deal with
that
yeah thanks again talia hope you had a
good stream
uh this is my second game of the stream
playing some some time in the chess
trying to keep it chill and educational
and yeah the game i played against this
opponent a few days ago
we had a similar position and i remember
when i checked stockfish afterwards
stockfish was recommending like very
slow play like rook c1
some queen b3 move at some point
it's also a cool idea to put the bishop
on b1 then a
2 and just align with the king f pawn is
looking tender
so h3 or h6
h6 is sometimes it's sometimes a sign of
aggression but it's also a sign black
just wants to prevent me from
accessing g5
i think i'll play queen c2
i was thinking about this move but then
[Music]
it's not easy to move the bishop without
losing the pawn
and there's another idea here for white
to play knight f1 to g3
and the queen helps um it's called
overproduction
[Music]
uh if i played knight f1 too soon after
takes takes upon his hanging
so over over protecting the pawn will
allow me to mobilize the knight
and then i think i guess long term when
the knight
comes to g3 again it helps over protect
the pawn and the queen will be able to
access d2
which is kind of what i want
because on d2 the knight's a bit in the
way
also thinking the queen could go to a2
and then the bishop can come here and
there's some like cool battery
maybe combine that with knight here and
maybe the opponent will be careless
just trying to identify like all the
potential
[Music]
resources i have in the position
also b4 b4 could be it's a bit
confrontational
but the idea is to just gain more space
and
maybe eventually play b5
hey it's gary what's up gary
shout out to ari
grandmaster gary eric rosen rose to the
rise and as
risen wait eric rosen rose
to rise and has risen good evening
you need to include something about
raisin in that sense
oh good evening to whirl away and thanks
for subbing jj spartan
and bedamp two skilled new
subscribers i appreciate that
oh gary if you just arrived
i don't know if you heard the
announcement but it's toggy's birthday
currently have to wish him happy
birthday
we can celebrate him with toggy bits as
well
okay so this move actually has some
attacking ideas
a very typical kind of king's indian
move
now there's less attack against the pawn
there is a response like sometimes when
the knight moves to h5
uh g3 is a nice prophylactic move
if i play g3 then it would probably make
sense to maneuver the bishop
i'm not sure how necessary that is
i mean i don't think i want to allow
this though
i guess now that f4 then i have bishop
f1 and g3
or even bishop c4
and d5 is another move i can actually
like with b4
of the longer term ideas that after
takes takes
i can get the pawns rolling with d5 97
c4
and then maybe black can more easily
play
f5
and there's bishop b5 here just
threatening d5
but the rook actually probably wants to
move back
so what to do
um just trying to weigh my options look
for
some other ideas there's also knight f1
going with the original plan and then
playing queen d2
which would hen and fight for the f4
square
actually it looks kind of interesting
knight f1 knight f4
bishop c4 i guess on g5
hmm
it's nice keeping the bishop here
because it slows down black's
ability to play f5 so i think i'll play
g3
just not dealing with this shenanigan
it's a single shenanigan
and then
my thought is all i'll kind of play
slowly
but there's a couple ideas one is to
play knight f1
actually there's two ideas but they both
start with the same
moves moves are knight f1 and queen here
and the two ideas is one to play g4
to chase away the knight or to play
knight h2 to g4
and attack the pawn
um so let's play i'm playing that f1
here
gotta start moving a little bit quicker
oh taki's birthday is january 7th
wait what's today oh it's january 6th
okay yeah iceland time
works differently than u.s time
i guess okay so box unleashing the
bishop
it's actually a good move
i mean my thought is that all i'll be
just in time
because i'm attacking the pawn if i
fight i
can i get away with taking
i may have messed up here
or maybe i didn't mess up or maybe i did
i don't know
okay that makes me happy f5 was actually
kind of complicated
because my knight's not defended there
is a pin and fork potential
um but now i can play g4
and here i'm just in time where
if 94 i win the pawn if not f6 uh
night blocks upon and then i can get my
my happy development thank you johnny
page
gifting their first sub to
[Music]
hirfti appreciate that
also thank you m emt cornbread
with 200 bits am i planning to play
viewers at all
um i'm not sure
i mean if i for most of my games i'm
just joining the pool
and then i guess my opponents could
see that i'm streaming and then become a
viewer
but i'm not doing like the typical uh
viewer challenges
this is really nice because i'm
controlling f5
a bunch of times and that's one of
black's main pawn rigs
it still takes work though
maybe before here
wait is f5 actually a threat
because there's a pin still which i
almost forgot about
f5 might be a threat
and d5 and d5 allows knight c5
there should be a few ways to handle
this
i could move the night like to weird
places
maybe i will
this is not my first impression i also
have to move a lot quicker
but i'm getting off the diagonal so f5 i
can just take and
and be happy yeah e4 is a good move
so maybe what i'll do is play f4 and win
connect four
there's still connect 8 potential this
pawn is kind of annoying though
yeah the problem is now
if i play d5 and like gets a post here
and it's really hard to remove with uh
with b4 because the pawn can always take
but opponents may be not sure what to do
wow plays f5 anyway
so if i take
i feel like i should take this way first
this is open but things are opening up
so i guess one line is takes this move
oh there's a cool line takes e4 it takes
takes and then knight e6
oh there's a cool line for black too but
maybe it doesn't work
i don't think it works
i mean black might go for the exchange
sack
um yeah this diagonal is kind of
annoying
i can't allow the queen to get here here
if quinji it was checked i would be in
some some danger
okay so h3 is attacked i do have d5
rook g8 is coming yeah i
think i should play d5 on d5 there's
knight f6
it's getting unclear
maybe f3 first
and then d5 eventually
i mean i'm not the exchange so all i
have to do is pretty much not get mated
and not blender a queen
yeah i want to play d5 soon
[Music]
because this pawn this pawn is only
defended by
i guess it's defended by the brook and
the knight but i've taken my knights
pinned
and the main goal is to play uh rook g1
eventually
i mean for a few moves there the bishop
was probably like black's strongest
one of the strongest weapons for black
but now it's kind of just a dead piece
and nice thing about being up the
exchange i can
more easily control open file
play this move first
maybe just go for the queen trade next
um that's a fancy move
queen g2 i mean maybe queen c2 is the
way to go
so now there's a nice kind of shish
kebab
of pieces and if rookie 8 i can take
attacking the queen twice and that could
lead to a lot of uh
simplification
okay yeah we're trading queens
so i'm up the exchange for a pawn play
rook f3
yeah rook f3 id rook h3
i mean time is probably the biggest
concern
going after this pawn i mean black could
maybe win that pawn
ooh
ah okay it's still okay
take here
or maybe it's not okay i don't know
no okay opponent missed something there
ah i miss something else there
that's why chess comes down to you
sometimes
i held on to my rook i really tried
blundering the rook
unintentionally blundered it here
and then also uh here oh wait there's no
i thought i allowed this but the
bishop's pinned
okay i mean
that started as kind of like a cool
instructional
positional middle game and just turned
into
like mud throwing
in the end
wash my hands that's why it's why hand
sanitizer
exists
man when i when i press down the
sanitizer shoots
like sideways and doesn't go completely
down
but i'm adjusting okay
and i'm sanitizing
um i'm black was pretty resourceful that
game
because i thought i thought it should be
it should be pretty smooth sailing from
here but
this was a nice concept going after the
pawn and then
like when my pawns crumble and it
becomes very difficult
now the bishop's also hanging so
[Music]
oh i should have taken the bishop here
and then black doesn't have time to take
the pawn has to take the bishop and then
i can win this pawn
i guess i was already low on time
oh thank you little one huzzah yeah
people need to say huzzah more often
oh africa africa with 30 months
that's a lot of months that's 10 times
3.
it's 10 times 3 or five times six
oh tier two sub two thanks so much
appreciate that
um
i'm sure i made some mistakes this game
maybe i didn't choose the best plan
the engine sometimes has a hard time
showing like the best approach
it will suggest moves but it doesn't
always suggest like a clear plan
okay this idea i know
yeah the engine likes d5 but i think
practically
um
it's easier for black when the center
closes because then black can
gear up towards playing f5 but maybe it
will also be easier for me
a4 here oh a4 maybe i can win the pawn
i'll say 97
oh just play i could go for like the
squeeze approach
yeah if i play this opponent again maybe
i'll play a little bit differently
oh already yeah f5 here i was scared of
this move
because black's fighting to fork me and
i can't take because i lose a knight
and if i take here
maybe it's still unclear
fe4 oh i'm still losing a piece
or maybe it's just really messy man this
engine line
bishop g7 rook f3 i just leave my bishop
here
and play bishop e2
[Music]
queen d7 as stockfish is ridiculous
sometimes